after the birth of jane ives the
telekinetically powered girl commonly
known as 11 in 1971 dr martin brenner
could only perform limited experiments
until she was old enough to perform some
larger tests these tests are what led to
her interacting with the demigorgon in
roughly 1983 but its history may go much
deeper than what we see on screen the
demogorgon is an otherworldly creature
so to understand it we're going to look
at how its form was inspired by the
beasts of our world and analyze its
story seen in stranger things and the
stranger things comic series i'll also
be exploring what really happened to the
demogorgon and the hidden connection it
shares with 11. so stick around to the
end of this video to hear all about it
this video is sponsored by raycon
the demogorgon is a monster from an
alternate dimension that spent its life
in darkness and decay stalking around
the area referred to as mirkwood to find
its next meal before slipping back
behind the curtain that separates its
cold abyss from our own dimension
welcome to horror history in this video
i'll be covering the being known as the
demogorgon and in future videos i'll go
over other members of the demogorgon
species it's kind of like how an alien
we have the xenomorph who is also part
of the xenomorph species the actual name
of the demogorgon or its species is not
known the characters just come up with
that name based on this demon prince
character from the game that they're
playing dungeons and dragons which may
be partially based off the forbidden
primeval god from ancient greek
mythology not much is known about the
demogorgon prior to its appearance in
hawkins however in analyzing what the
demogorgon truly represents and embodies
the community of hawkins we have to take
this all the way back to the 1940s roll
the horror history screen
with the cold war spanning the majority
of the 20th century americans were
generally concerned about communism
spreading through their communities and
the government this eventually led to
mccarthyism and truman's loyalty program
in an attempt to curb the worries of the
citizens mccarthyism was a campaign from
1950 to 1954 that was run by senator
joseph mccarthy who claimed that there
were communists hiding in plain sight in
the us government along with other major
institutions it's basically like how
there are people who are subscribed to
this channel but they don't have the
death belen like i know you're out there
and i will find you mccarthyism devolved
into basically an early version of
cancel culture where people who may be
more communist ended up on blacklists
and sometimes lost their jobs so the
truman loyalty program was made to root
out communists and prevent them from
entering government positions but you're
probably wondering what the frick this
has to do with old flower face over here
i swear i'm getting to that so you may
remember in season 3 semi-spoiler alert
for season 3 i guess that the kids
discover a whole russian communist
operation underneath the town but the
original damagorgan and the experiments
at hawkins lab served as a more covert
symbol for the communist agenda way back
in the first season i don't know why i'm
saying way back as if it was really that
long ago so anyway the us central
intelligence agency was disturbed and
intrigued by prisoners of war coming
back from the korean war and talking
about communist propaganda and they
believe this could be a form of russian
mind control so they launched project
mk-ultra in april of 1953. despite how
it sounds this was no electronic music
festival they used certain active
substances to try to make advancements
in mind control to combat russia in
stranger things the hawkins national lab
uses mk-ultra to explain how eleven
might have obtained her psychokinetic
abilities it's suggested through her
mother's participation in secret
experiments that continued on past the
initial end of mkultra which was
sometime in 1973. you can actually see
mkultra included in part of an article
title in a newspaper story about hawkins
laboratory that hopper finds in the
library this article is potentially from
around 1975 which is when some of the
details of the project were initially
released to the public so the fear of
trouble and hawkins that arises when
residents start going missing is akin to
the hysteria that swept across america
during the communist scare lasting until
the ussr dissolved in the early 90s it's
been suggested that the demigorgon is
the upside-down version of l seeing as
how they are the only ones of their
kinds to exhibit telekinesis there are
other examples which we'll get to 11 was
born in 71 but dr brenner held larger
tests that led to her interaction with
the demogorgon in roughly 1983. her
first encounter with it is when she sent
telepathically to listen to a russian
man's conversation we don't see the
demogorgon in the scene however we are
able to hear it screech or is it a roar
this could be because 11 and the
demogorgon are linked and its scream is
because it shares the same fear that she
holds being forced into the deprivation
tank the scream sounds like a cross
between a dinosaur and a slowed down
orangutan
it also sounds a little bit like me
whenever i get put on hold all
representatives are currently assisting
other customers please stay on the line
11 is encouraged by brenner to face the
monster she saw again by diving back
into the sensory deprivation tanks when
she does find it the demogorgon feeds on
what looks like either a giant egg
similar to the one seen in the upside
down or a tree stump covered in sap only
when she touches its back is when it
finally acknowledges her and lets out a
massive roar we're sorry all of our
representatives are still busy
this scares eleven back into our reality
once she's met with the demogorgon's
face which opens like a series of flower
petals resembling a squid's tentacles
opening to engulf its prey the
damagorgan has a series of sharp canines
while squids have sharp rings on their
clubbed tentacles to help grip their
prey effectively and rip it apart the
comparison holds up in later scenes
where we see the demogorgon eating in a
similar style including the squid's
tendency to start eating prey while it's
still alive like one of those korean
mukbang chicks the next time the
demogorgon appears is when the gate
between the upside down and our
dimension is opened on november 6 1983.
it takes this chance to hunt everyone in
the lab that it can locate we can assume
it devoured as much as it could in the
short time span in a similar way to how
some carnivores engage in what is known
as opportunity hunting for example
you'll see bears do this because they
need to quickly gain enough weight for
hibernation the demogorgon could share a
similar mentality since fresh food is
usually a limited resource for it in the
upside down which is mainly void of
other life forms you'll also notice that
11 has to relieve her hunger around this
time but her victims come in the form of
eggo waffles rather than returning to
the upside down the flower face becomes
the enemy in the shadows and begins
roaming the woods around town for fresh
prey it specifically stays in the same
area will and his friends call merkwood
the area it stays in is small because
it's the closest area to the portal and
because it's the same area that will is
hiding in in the upside down on the
surface hawkins is your standard small
town america where nothing really
happens and everyone is somewhat
familiar with each other it's 1983 and
most of the families we see are the
typical nuclear family the cold war
frequently comes up in conversation
usually through references to russian
commies or communists while hawkins
doesn't stand out as being special and
is meant to be the stereotypical small
town from the 80s it does highlight the
nagging sense of anxiety that everyone
around you could be a communist below
the surface for the residents life is
fairly simple with lines being drawn to
distinguish what is considered normal
and what is not things that are not
normal are frequently met with criticism
and disbelief which reflects on the
mentality during the cold war where
americans were on high alert about
potential communists this is reflected
in how the town treats certain families
the buyers live in a secluded area
that's just outside of town and joyce is
divorced despite having two kids and a
dog they don't fit the standard white
picket fence idea of a perfect family
the series even opens with a peek into
how their lifestyle is not so average
with it jonathan has taken an almost
father-like role while also trying to be
will's older brother then we have the
wheeler family they serve as what is
considered the typical nuclear family
nancy describes her parents marriage as
her mother marrying well finding the
perfect house at the end of the
cul-de-sac and raising the perfect
family in the perfect house
i don't think my parents ever loved each
other you must have married for some
reason my mom was young
my dad was older
but he had a cushy job
money
came from a good family
so they bought a nice house at the end
of the cul-de-sac
started their nuclear family then she
perfectly shoots a can when she's never
handled a gun before in the same way she
gets everything right on her flash cards
on the night of november 6 will byers is
going home after a dnd campaign with his
friends and cuts through murkwood this
is when the demogorgon comes after will
and the lights flicker as he runs from
it we don't see the monster in the scene
but we can hear it screeching in the
night this could potentially be it using
sound in a similar way to how bats use
sonar waves to detect objects in order
to navigate through the dark since the
demogorgon doesn't appear to have eyes
nancy and jonathan also later determined
that the demogorgon hunts by tracking
blood similar to a shark when it catches
up with him the demigorgon is able to
warp will into the upside down by
weakening the fabric between the
dimensions and like a shark the creature
closes in on its meal
i can't believe how long it's been since
we did one with raikon i actually still
have my original pair that they sent me
over two years ago they still work but i
like the black ones gotta stay on brand
i'm using these things all the time
during my workouts and runs for some
reason other brands don't really make
these things ear shaped so they just
fall out but the raycons stay in thanks
to their optimized gel tips the new
everyday earbuds offer an improved
rubber oil look and feel with eight
hours of play time you can listen to the
first 12 weezer albums in one sitting
and thanks to the charging case you get
32 hours of battery life overall there's
also a built-in mic so you can take
calls at the press of a button hold on
oh hey pewdiepie yeah i'm recording a
recon ad right now i can help you with
your content strategy stuff a little bit
later all right later raycon started
half the price of other premium audio
brands but they sound just as good and
come with a 45-day happiness guarantee
you already know what to do click the
link in the description box or go to
buyrecon.com
world to unlock exclusive deals up to
twenty percent off your recon order
that's by recon dot com slash cz's world
after chasing the demogorgon off by
firing the gun will wanders around in
the upside downs version of his house
where he struggles to communicate with
his mom or anyone from the top side will
explores the distorted version of his
house and eventually falls asleep
beneath the jaws poster in his mock room
maybe a clue about the creature's blood
sensing abilities back on the surface
the town itself is temporarily thrown
into a seemingly lackluster disarray
when it's announced that will byers went
missing on his way home even police
chief hopper initially takes the
information almost lightheartedly when
joyce includes the detail that will's a
target of bullying at school along with
will's father calling him here
this line of questioning along with
joyce begging hopper to believe her can
parallel a representation of truman's
loyalty policies these insist that
people should trust the government to do
what was necessary to keep communism out
of their neighborhoods it's only after
joyce answers hopper's questions that he
appears more interested in the case
unfortunately for hawkins the monster
that infiltrated their town is far more
than a communist the demigorgon's
presence shows the nature of the
hysteria involved with speculating that
there's a communist hiding next door we
can get a grasp on this representation
by using aspects from the first chapter
of jeffrey cohen's monster theory along
with a historical perspective the book
presents seven theses each involving
various creatures being a symbolic
representation of the cultures that
created them for the infiltration of
hawkins we can refer to thesis number
four where monsters are embodiments of
what's different cohen writes that the
creature can be a form of the other and
in this case that other is the russians
when will wakes up to find himself still
trapped in the upside down he tries to
communicate with his mom the activity
ends up attracting the demogorgon back
to him as a form of connection is
established through a super calm luckily
will manages to scare the demogorgon off
a second time by shooting at but uses
the last of his ammunition meanwhile
search parties continue combing the
woods for well but his friends are not
content with sitting at home doing
nothing eleven tries to explain where
will is by flipping their dnd board over
and placing will's wizard token in the
center hiding
from the bad man there's no such thing
as the bad man shut up gordon you don't
show up till season three elle places
the demogorgon token next to will's
wizard piece this explains how they come
to associate the name demogorgon with
the monster a name that sticks from then
on i've also seen it suggested that the
demogorgon token having two heads could
be a potential clue about duality if in
fact the demogorgon is the upside down
version of eleven on tuesday night nancy
wheeler brings her friend barb to a
party at steve harrington's house barb
ends up sitting by the pool after
cutting her hand and a blood drop falls
into the water which is likely what drew
the demogorgon to her it appears behind
her as seen in jonathan byers
photographs and brings her into the
upside down barb screams echo through
the upside down as she's dragged into
the empty pool by the demogorgon will
who is still hiding there can hear her
screams along with the demogorgon's cry
and he runs out towards the screams in
an attempt to help her but he's too late
will returns to the upside down version
of his home and is able to talk to his
mom again but also draws the
demogorgon's attention again this time
it goes for mrs byers by ripping a hole
in the wall andy bernard style it seems
to be able to sense where the veil
between the worlds is thinner and it'll
prioritize getting more people rather
than always taking the easiest targets i
mean it's obviously to make the show
more dramatic but if i had to give it a
logical reason uh yeah let's go with
that thing i said we see a similar scene
later on this time will takes his mom's
advice and runs for it then in the
underground lab a scientist explores the
upside down communicating via the
microphone in his suit he is basically
the demogorgon equivalent of that light
up cyanide krispy kreme that says hot
doughnuts when the other scientists
desperately try to pull him back they
end up with just some spine and rib cage
tied to the chain that was around his
waist hey at least food's not going to
waste since the demogorgon has
infiltrated hawkins from the upside down
it's easy to say that the upside down
itself is the equivalent of the iron
curtain the iron curtain was an implied
wall in europe that separated areas
controlled by the soviet union and
western controlled allies those who
crossed over to the soviet side of the
curtain in the mid 80s may be greeted
with floating particles of ash similar
to those seen in the upside down because
that's exactly what happened after the
chernobyl disaster in 1986 when a
reactor melted down and forced
evacuations for hundreds of miles around
the city of pripyat this could also
explain why the upside down is mostly
deserted other than this strange mutated
creature these attributes could also be
related to the meltdown in three mile
island in pennsylvania in the u.s which
was designed to compete with russian
advances in nuclear technology just as
godzilla rose from japan in the fallout
of their nuclear disaster history itself
can become the monster and events of
days past can turn fears of
contamination into the horrors on your
tv screen or whatever the [ __ ] you watch
the show on nancy and jonathan decide to
hunt down the demogorgon in the woods
they stumble across a dying deer but
before putting it out of its misery
it's abruptly geeted back into the
bushes nancy ends up following the red
trail through a portal at the base of a
tree and discovers the demogorgon well
we've all seen someone do this at the
local discount buffet right it uses its
squid-like face to rip its meal to
pieces not even realizing that there are
other patrons at the buffet however when
the demogorgon does realize that nancy
is there it chases her into hiding and
traps her by blocking the portal back to
the real world which tells us that the
monster does have some intelligence
nancy hears jonathan's voice calling
from the other side of the tree portal
which seems to be closing but nancy
isn't the only one who hears him will is
also close enough to hear his brother
and ends up finding nancy along with the
portal and the demogorgon instead of
going for the portal himself will
distracts the demogorgon with the rock
so nancy can escape the demogorgon takes
the next easy meal the hunter henry who
had been recently trapped in the upside
down exhausted and beginning to
hallucinate will goes to the last safe
place he can think of castle buyers
unfortunately for him it's not as safe
as he believes
as will lays in his fort castle buyers
eleven visits him psycho kinetically to
tell him that his mother is coming for
him and to hold on a little while longer
after she vanishes will starts muttering
the lyrics to his favorite the clash
song okay well i see you but
unfortunately so does the demogorgon
sending it straight to his location if
11 and the demogorgon are linked it
stands to reason that when eleven found
will she accidentally tipped off his
location basically anything she knows
the demogorgon knows and this happens
multiple times we see a similar concept
with will and the mind flayer in season
2. it seems to be implied that will is
unable to escape this time but our
friend flowerface has bigger plans for
him than simply making him a midnight
snack will finds himself deep within the
creature's nest with some kind of
face-hugging organism plastered to his
mouth i'm guessing this is because will
is so small that the demogorgon would
prefer to make him a carrier rather than
a meal this log implanted within him
appears to be the demogorgon's offspring
i don't know if that makes the
demogorgon male or female and i don't
really want to think about it so let's
just skip to nancy and jonathan setting
up the trap on friday the 11th they end
up cutting their own palms to lure it
back to the smell of their blood however
the monster is too powerful and knocks
jonathan down while surviving every
bullet nancy has in her gun which kind
of begs the question why it was afraid
of will's gun earlier on but i mean
maybe it was just a case of the creature
not knowing its own power like how if
you tie down an elephant with a small
rope it won't realize that it can escape
just before it's about to strike nancy
steve harrington rushes in using the
nailed bat and starts taking it to the
monster chris bryant style the three of
them managed to get the monster's foot
stuck in the bear trap and light it on
fire as jonathan puts the flames out
they find the beast gone only the
dissolving remnants of flesh clinging to
the trap presumably having been driven
back into its own dimension while chief
hopper and will's mom are rescuing him
from the upside down and dr brenner and
his people storm the school to try to
kidnap 11. she uses her abilities to
squeeze the brains of all the bad men
threatening her friends but the use of
her powers once again causes a nosebleed
and attracts the demogorgon the kids run
to try to get to safety in the science
classroom the boys scream for lucas to
get the wrist rocket out as the
demogorgon breaks down the door
following the scent of eleven's blood
while the rocks don't actually do much
damage eleven recovers just enough to
send the monster flying into the back
wall and with a parting farewell
proceeds to disintegrate the damage
organ disappearing into the upside down
herself as she does so it's very
interesting how when they come face to
face they are practically mirror images
of each other and the only way for l to
defeat it or get rid of it hurts her and
transports her to the upside down this
isn't proof that she's the demogorgon
and the demogorgon is her but i can't
ignore the fact that she sees herself as
the monster
oh
my
sorry
sorry what are you sorry for
the game
i opened it
i'm the monster so if l is the
demogorgon and she survives this battle
seemingly being transported back to the
upside down it's possible that old
flower faith survives too just as the
idea of communism has somehow survived
over many wars and many years or it
could just be that the creature seen in
russia at the end of the third season is
just another member of the same species
either way the analogy probably stands
if you want to see the histories of more
horror monsters click that playlist on
the left we've got more stranger things
episodes coming so remember to subscribe
to cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]